we continue our countdown on the top
story lines for the 2019 season and
number 14 relates to a guy who was one
of the big stories heading into 2018
Kirk Cousins hitting free agency getting
84 million fully guaranteed on a
three-year contract for a Vikings team
that was one game away from making it
back to the Super Bowl for the first
time since 1976 can Kirk Cousins become
something more than what he has
described himself as a quarterback who
is essentially 500 for his career the
Vikings were 87 and one last year just a
little bit over 500 but not good enough
to get to the postseason this year if
they don't make it to the playoffs again
I think the Viking didn't have real
questions about whether they want to
keep cousins around for 2020 the problem
is his contracts fully guaranteed for
2020 unless they find a trade partner
and he waives his no-trade clause
they've got no choice but to keep him
around
the Vikings are hoping that they can
surround Kirk Cousins with enough help
that will allow him to be something more
than a 500 quarterback because really
even though the quarterback gets all the
credit when things go well and all the
blame when things go poorly it's about
so much more than the quarterback and
for the Vikings with an offensive line
that was not good last year in the
passing of offensive line coach Tony
Sparano just before the start of
training camp threw a wrench into the
plans of the Vikings to try to be as
good as they were in 2017 this year
things have settled down this year
they've got expectations with
first-round pick Garrett Bradbury at
center tight end Kyle Rudolph has
recently raved about what Bradbury can
do in that offense the defense is still
very good if they can get enough out of
the offensive line to get enough out of
the running game to make it easier for
Kirk Cousins to find targets down the
field to set up some play-action passes
the Vikings can win some games they need
to win in primetime but the good news is
even though they have five prime time
games this year the first one comes week
8 at home on a Thursday night against
Washington we'll know whether or not the
Vikings are going to be competitive long
before they have some difficult
prime-time road games in places like
Dallas and Seattle and LA against the
charters the Vikings could turn it
around they could get back to the
playoffs and when they get there the
question becomes can Kirk Cousins win
postseason games but before that happens
he's gonna have to be a better than 500
quarterback whether he is is one of the
top stories heading into the 2019 CS
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports